every summer Bianca's parents take the
family camping somewhere warmer and
greener than home Bianca and her brother
Mark love this holiday time especially
when they can do their own thing while
Mom and Dad go sightseeing they like to
stay in touch with their friends and to
share things about the country they are
visiting a few years ago with her first
phone Bianca used up her prepaid card in
a couple of days by texting her friends
at home all the time
Now using messaging apps she shows her
gang the pics and video of the guitarist
who plays in the old town every
evening in 2009 she just couldn't
because the huge phone bill would mean
that her parents would ground her for 2
weeks and stop her pocket money for a
month but today Bianca can tell her
friends everything about the guitarist
because data roaming is much cheaper and
sending a photo or Video cost the same
as a text message a few years
ago Bianca can even catch up with her
friends at night at the
campsite this is how things work thanks
to roaming price caps her parents are
happy they can call and text the
grandparents to check if everything is
okay at home and Bianca can enjoy being
digital even on holiday as of summer
2014 you will now pay maximum 20 cents
per megabyte when
roaming which means that for € you can
post a pick on Facebook and WhatsApp
send an email get lost in a city center
and find your way with your map app read
the news and look forward to when the
new European commission proposal could
mean the end of roaming in Europe
altogether this means saving some money
for planning your next holidays in
Europe have a great summer and stay
updated on the Telecom single Market at
#c Connected
continent